I'll be honest is the first thing I've
done all day I know if you can tell well
first thing I've done if you don't count
Netflix which I know where you guys
stand on that but me personally I'm done
with Netflix and I don't mean I'm bored
with it I mean I'm almost done watching
everything that has ever been made hats
off to and they keep adding stuff but I
got a lot of time one thing I've learned
from watching all of Netflix is you
start to appreciate John Rizzo film that
you thought you hated like for instance
I was never a fan of 80s cop movies I
always thought they were cheesy and
stuff until I saw all of them now I get
it
haha my favorite scene in any 80s cop
movie and this is in every single one of
them to see where there's a drug bust
and then some tough play by his own
rules detective comes over rips open the
bag of drugs dips a pinkie in tastes it
and it goes yep
pure uncut cocaine Oh classic scene I
love it I just wish they would show that
same cop five minutes later when he's
like hey guys guys guys guys guys guys
listen up guys we need to get some more
cocaine dealers
now I've also been watching a lot of
serial killer documentaries slightly I'm
not a weirdo or anything I don't admire
what they do but I am impressed by how
much they get done they're productive
people let's watch one the other night
on the Zodiac killer he's one of my
faves and at one point in the
documentary they say they thought they
found two victims that were the work of
the zodiac but they turned out to be the
work of a copycat killer
and then they just kind of move on that
is very alarming to me you had this
dismissive attitude towards copycat
killers like they're a cover band or
something the police are not very
concerned really you're just like I
don't pay him no mind
he's a wannabe I mean yes he's really
killing people but he's so unoriginal
about it you know me murder let's messed
up a plagiarism what a psychopath
that's all a real-life psychopath about
a month ago I was on a flight completely
overbook flight pack with people I had a
window seat this guy in front of me also
window seat this guy
farts audibly I mean people are looking
at him and he's just looking around like
an idiot
after a while it starts to smell which
inevitably it wilts from inside your
body right so after it starts smell guy
don't know what to do so then he just
slides the window visor up smart bacon
Macie house behind the grossest [ __ ]
ever who thinks it's totally cool to
just rip one on a crowded flight not do
anything about it and be like oh my bad
let me shed a little light on that it's
okay I heated it up for the rest of the
plane it's disgusting
some good things are happening for me
though I'm not just getting farted on my
girlfriend and I had just celebrated a
three year anniversary by breaking up
sorry that's misleading we did break up
but don't feel bad for me it really was
for the best you know we just were never
on the same page really like a prime
example a few months back I was hanging
out in her friend's house and his friend
of mine he was going through a breakup
at the time and my girlfriend called me
to see where I was at I told her and she
goes oh you're at Jeff's place do me a
favor give him a hug for me it was like
ah yeah sure I'll tell him you said
hello I guess I know everything gets
hugging but you know I don't ask other
people to do it for me
uh-huh I don't contract that out to
people I wouldn't do that to my friends
you know me better guys Steve what's up
what are you doing oh man you're at
Jeff's place do me a favor bro embrace
him but do it for me all right use your
body as my body and convey my emotions
for me that's weird
basically my girlfriend was asking me to
be a part of the worst threesome
possible which ban threesome for me two
guys one girl worst threesome two guys
one girl who's there in spirit
guys that's right hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos